Mock ribbing is a great alternative
for machine knitters to using a ribber,
hand-manipulating,
or hand-knitting ribbing.
In a previous video, we discussed
options for creating beautiful mock ribs.
But how do you seam them?
With a little planning, you can have
beautiful seams in your mock ribs.
Now, one note, you may have to adjust
the number of stitches you cast on to work
these tips,
but you can always adjust your stitch
count after you've
completed your mock ribs.
Let's take a look at one by one mock ribs.
While you're planning your cast on,
be sure that you have a stitch
on both edges of the knitting.
This will be dedicated
as a seaming stitch.
As you mattress stitch the seam,
just pick up half of each edge stitch.
Done neatly, you'll have a whole stitch
along that seam, and it
will not be noticeable.
Remember, you'll want to continue seaming
one half of that edge stitch
beyond the mock ribbing.
For two by one mock ribs,
make sure you have two stitches
on each end of the knitting.
This time, you'll mattress stitch between
the two edge stitches as you
normally would with mattress stitch.
This will allow you to continue the two
stitch pattern repeat across your seam.
Three by one mock rib takes
a little more planning.
Now, let's say you're using
this for a sock or mitten cuff.
Set up your mock rib with two stitches
on one edge and three
stitches on the other edge.
When you fold the work to create the cuff,
you'll mattress stitch between the edge
stitches and still maintain
a three-stitch column intact.
If seaming mock ribbing has kept you from
using it, please practice these seams.
Mock ribbing is a great technique
for your machine knitting bag of tricks.